exclusive ipsos polling conducted for
global news finds two-thirds of
canadians would take a booster shot
without hesitation
still just over half 53 percent say they
are concerned about potential long-term
effects of boosters and how many shots
will be needed in the future
75 of respondents agreed booster shots
lessen the chance of hospitalization
while 66 percent feel they prevent
infection yeah i think what you're
seeing over time is that the urgency
about all of this is in decline people
certainly accept the arguments that uh
getting a booster shot reduces the
chance that they'll end up in hospital
reduces the chance that they may
actually get covet
but their sense that um
you know the urgency around this uh is
not what it was uh say a year ago or 18
months ago where people have more
experience with the disease these days
and they think that they can basically
take their time so we don't see as much
urgency there's a there's an intention
to get
um to to get boosted
and and for people who
even are under vaccinated need more than
boosting uh there's an intention to do
it but there doesn't seem to be an
urgency to do it the the interesting
that's the thing that i see in this is
that when we go it's looking at this
over time so previously when we were
having these conversations about access
to vaccines it really was about the
question of access whether or not people
could actually obtain a shot so there
was a mad rush particularly at the start
of
of
vaccines being available to people
getting vaccinated the public's not
feeling that way at the moment they
still feel it's the right thing to do
they still feel that they should be uh
that there are benefits that are
associated with it
but the issue now isn't a concern about
access it's just
a combination of things like for example
not really feeling the need to do it
immediately and also a building level of
concern about what potentially the
long-term effects could be
of of of
of covet vaccine so there's a an
interesting mix of things that are
causing a certain amount of hesitancy
among the public but it's not like a
hostile hesitancy it's not a rejection
of science and
people saying i absolutely don't want to
do this they may have some questions but
also that emotional need to say i've got
to get it to save my life at this moment
isn't today what it was when we we first
started into uh making uh vaccines
accessible so the whole public opinion
environment around around vaccines has
has changed and actually quite honestly
it's starting to look more like what
people think about flu shots
as opposed to you know something that is
you know a protection against something
that could be really really urgently
deadly so it's it's becoming part of of
what people see is
i'm afraid to say almost like a normal
life i mean when we go and ask people
these days whether or not we'll ever get
it out of our our lives completely the
public doesn't believe that and when we
see in terms of the level of importance
that people put on fighting the the
covid pandemic a whole series of other
issues have passed it in terms of public
levels of concern particularly things
that relate to the economy which people
have a real urgency or sense of urgency
about covet is just one of those things
that we're learning to deal with we do
believe in the science we do believe
that we should be getting access to
vaccines we don't feel and some of the
numbers in this you know the sense that
it's as deadly as it once was that's
down about eight points so we're getting
experience dealing with the disease and
uh you know as i said before it's
starting to feel a little bit like the
way public opinion builds around things
like flu shots